I gotta meet the the record record guy
first place called VidCon it's like a
convention for social media stuff like
Viners and youtubers yeah I was the most
boring place in the world I'm gonna as a
youtuber I'm gonna just declare for you
guys right now that I was invited a bit
gone and don't worry these big-time
people are never gonna watch this and if
they do I'm sorry but you got to make
your event more interesting
hello guys I'm Ryan right I'm Danielle
I'm gonna introduce her to Rach a
racquet right now theyyou comedy
sketches that tend to go violent have
more dark their latest sketches band Red
Bull commercial
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Wow
they have such a dark sense of humor
they take a concept that sounds funny
like what if Red Bull just turns you
into like a violent monster but they
commit to it so much I capture it like a
drama or something or like very real
that way it's like disturbing but that's
what makes it funny
let's say these guys as sketches are
kind of inspiring to me because a lot of
my sketches tend to go like a really
dark path towards the end yeah but I
love their commitment to violence - yeah
like when the baby girl that was fun
that was funny when the baby popped out
that was pretty fun yeah that's the
funny day kids that's what makes it
funny baby can't read my favorite one
was when the angel wing popped out of
him like Green Team and wing popped out
of him because that was the most
unexpected one like the baby falling out
as grossest that was kind of saw it
coming
can't go a violent saw that coming the
one with the window didn't see that
coming that was pretty [ __ ] funny I
love that escalation of humor just like
getting more and more ridiculous and the
guy who had the wing come out of him
he's pretty good is he one of the people
not that I met I actually don't really
recognize I'm sure seeing another
sketches but he's pretty good yes
yeah do you like a body like that body
doesn't really matter to you mm-hmm
I mean John Goodman and my number one
you would die in sex with John good dude
if he gets on top of you
you're just you've lost a lot of weight
but you never affirm when he was heavier
dude people get it oh I get it now Red
Bull gives you wings yeah didn't catch
on in that before no I thought they were
ones about to but none of the other
people got wings what did that happen
with the pregnant woman why she'd become
a why'd that happen I didn't see her
drink red Bull the guy gets horns like a
bull charges at them oh yeah man the guy
gets Red Bull yeah wings the red the
blood right red
cuz it's so much flood red I know but
red pool wing I'm saying they get the
first two why the baby one them red the
[ __ ] are you talking she bleeds random
no [ __ ] she bleeds red there's like a
lot of things that could be red then she
could have pulled up all the way off
okay yeah you know I feel like it'd be
kind of cool to actually give birth like
that like standing and the baby just
pops out you rip off the umbilical cord
like if Veronica ever got pregnant I
would totally be down to have a
pregnancy like that seems more natural
you know I mean if it just slid right
out it'd be great it will be fantastic
do you wanna have a baby one day yeah
you do yeah how many kids do you want
just one just one boy or girl
he's did want a girl but now I want a
boy okay okay he's gonna be a total
man-whore do you think I think so
no you think positive because I really
wanna buy little shoes he's gonna pop
out of your vagina just fall out with an
erection I don't think in sunglasses I
don't think he's gonna just slide right
out doc is gonna have a big dick dick
first yeah I see a dick another day at
the real rejects people I wonder if
people accidentally cut the penis off
instead of the cord we should research
that oh okay
Mexican medical students licensed a
baby's penis inside in July 17th yep
it happens Wow well that's scary this
one article about this one individual
has me amigo I will never go to a
Mexican doctor just this one just this
one has entire race of doctors to me I
wonder if they sued I'm sure they did
yeah oh no I should happen it's no
really we wanted a girl anyway let's go
oh my god oh man I'd be so cool to have
a baby I'm on Veronica or a woman if
that I and a mare
to have a I have to be married that's
one thing for sure angry
I mean if it's an accident abortion I
honestly at the stage of my life like
I'm doing reasonably well right now and
so I feel like I don't feel like if
something happened where's like Veronica
got pregnant that I wouldn't want to
abort it I don't feel like I can live
with that like I have nothing yeah I
have nothing against people who think
abortion is okay I'm for pro-abortion
because I know that's their own belief
yeah for me personally I wouldn't want
it from my life I don't think anyone's
like I want to get an abortion one day
basically you just said you don't
believe in that but what if you were 16
if I was 16 I might have considered it
so you do believe in it just not at this
time in your life yeah I guess time in
my life I wouldn't do it okay but
probably when I was when I was younger
actually I was a really devoted Catholic
when I was younger so now would have
kept the baby and given up on my dreams
no yeah no or or given up for adoption
yes
we always forget about that
I think it's sadder and harder yeah when
I give up something that you raised
farmed better and harder Veronica says
it to me all the time it's sadder the
harder it gets sadder the dark we really
did yeah we barely even talked about the
video well we discussed a lot of it I
mean it's sparked the thought that we
went more in depth with and then the
actual reviewing the video itself anyway
guys if you're new to the channel click
this button today and subscribe so you
can become up reject yeah yeah and you
check out Danielle and check her out on
Instagram where it'll make her boyfriend
happy if you pleasure yourself to your
photos Veronica got a dick dick recently
Center a message on
she didn't ask for I read the message I
read the messages Danielle it's pretty
big
it's kind of curved there like that I
like you know if I'm gonna see a penis
I'm I'm like you know straight his kind
of curves like that she doesn't get
turned on my dick picks what girls like
oh yeah you know I could go online you
just click you know I'm honestly not
turned on by just a [ __ ] picture either
like I would need to see like you know
feels like it's like down angle so that
way you could see the face still but
just a vagina alone doesn't do it for me
what about a vagina what the baby's head
coming out yo no you found my weak spot
right there